you know we may have come a long way
from actually cutting and pasting film
together by hand
but editing remains one of the most
complex parts of the storytelling
process
editors have to comb through hours and
hours of footage and decide which takes
make the movie and which wind up on The
Cutting Room floor yeah
and whether working with a massive
machine like this one or at a computer
editors still accomplish the same
amazing feat translating time Rhythm and
performance into a compelling story on
screen
here are the nominees for achievement in
film editing
the Banshees of Innis Sharon Michael E.G
Nelson Elvis Matt Villa and Jonathan
Redmond everything everywhere all at
once Paul Rogers tar Monica Villi top
gun Maverick Eddie Hamilton
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to
everything everywhere all at once
editor Paul Rogers met the Daniels
directors of everything everywhere all
at once at Daniel shinard's birthday
party
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow this is uh this is too much this is
my second film y'all this is crazy
um
uh
I have to thank my wife the most
incredible woman in the room
um
my family my mama's up here somewhere I
don't know she'll scream there she is uh
uh my uh my Parallax family Luke Lynch
you know
um
my team Ashish
Jing and Carrie up there
and uh
Dan and Daniel wherever you are yeah
there you are uh I hope you know you
know look your friends the people who
care about you
we're not here because of the incredible
wonderful strange beautiful movies you
make we're here because you guys are
incredible with kind generous strange
sexy people and uh and we'll be if all
this goes away we're we're still here
with you uh to the cast it's been the
honor of my career
to work with you I hope I did right by
you uh I care deeply about every one of
you so um
yeah thank you
foreign
[Music]